all right new york governor andrew cuomo
revealing
uh reveling in the fact that the justice
department
is dropping their investigation into new
york nursing home deaths
it was toxic politics
it violated the basic concept of justice
in this nation
and it did a lot of harm and a lot of
damage to say to people who
lost a loved one in a nursing home
it could have been prevented it was a
mistake
by government bureaucrats that's why
your loved one died
how cruel wow our next guest both lost
family members in nursing homes due to
the governor's policies
joining me now is our very own senior
meteorologist janis dean and new york
assemblyman ron kim who've become fast
friends through this
and allies because they want to get to
the truth
first off janice for you was this the
right time for him to say he was
exonerated
no but i'm so used to this and i'm sure
ron will say the same thing he's like a
broken record he blames
everybody else except the guy that
signed the mandate for 46 days to put
covet positive patience into nursing
homes and the the new york post this
morning
got it absolutely right here it is
liar he's a liar and they chronicle this
iran kim ron what exactly did the doj uh
do and what exactly is left to these
investigations first into the nursing
homes
doj closed the original investigation
that's what it seems like into the
publicly
run facilities which is this very small
portion
of the entire nursing home industry
so the civil investigation is still open
for the entire nursing homes
and the criminal investigation more
importantly is still ongoing
for the governor to go take the media
national stage and tell
and take a victory lap and play the
victim
while thousands of families like janice
and mine are still seeking the truth
that is what's cruel ron here's the
thing
he melissa de rose's chief of staff told
democratic lawmakers on a call
that they basically apologize for
stonewalling when it comes to the total
deaths
he's kind of on the record is he going
to throw her under the bus
he will do whatever he has to do say and
do
to save his own behind he is a dangerous
man that's drowning
and we need to continue to hold him
accountable and
he thinks this is toxic politics this is
not politics this is about
accountability so we can get the state
in the right direction so we don't
repeat the same mistakes
janice is he uh he feels like he's been
thrown a life preserver and is now on
shore should he feel as though he beat
all these investigation what's left
he better prepare for the ag's report
which is coming in the next couple of
weeks and there are
multiple investigations here in the new
york attorney general yeah absolutely
there's an fbi investigation and the new
york attorney general's
investigation that's supposed to come
out in the next couple of weeks i think
he has to prepare himself
and i would love for him to talk to
victims families
in a town hall and tell us face to face
that he's the victim and see what
happens but he won't
because he's a coward and a bully so i
know you guys understandably are focused
on the
nursing homes but what is also left is
he's at
at least 10 sexual harassment accusers
also
when in his book using staff to write
his book got five million dollars as an
advance
is that an ethics violation also was he
giving his friends and family special
consideration
like his brother when it came to testing
ron how much do these other
investigations matter
and what's he doing about his own ag
democratic a.g
investigating him it's all a pattern of
abuse of power and abusive behavior here
he chased down a 5.1 million dollar book
deal at the peak of the pandemic
that is that is the main reason why he
committed fraud he himself last year
said it is criminal fraud to lie about
nursing home death toll and that is
precisely what he did
and we need to again hold him
accountable for that
and already janice he's starting to
marginalize the investigation by leticia
james
let's say using surrogates to say it's
all political real quick
well absolutely he's trying to you know
demean her her
investigation into him basically saying
that she's going to run for governor so
that's why she's doing this
uh and to all those victims i mean he's
shaming them again
so you know this needs to be this
governor needs to go
if new york doesn't understand that yet
wake
up right he is not out of the woods
don't let his arrogance fool you
ron kim jennistein thanks so much you're
welcome